every weekend for as long as i can
remember
my father would get up on a saturday
put on a worn sweatshirt
and it'd scrape away at the squeaky old
wheel of a house that we lived in
i wouldn't even call it restoration it
was a ritual catharsis
he would spend all year scraping paint
with this old heat gun and a spackle
knife and then he'd repaint where he
scraped only to begin again the
following year
scraping and re-scraping painting and
repainting
the work of an old house is never meant
to be done
the day my father turned 52 i got a
phone call my mother was on the line to
tell me that doctors had found a lump in
his stomach terminal cancer she told me
and he had been given only three weeks
to live
i immediately moved home to poughkeepsie
new york
to sit with my father on death watch not
knowing what the next days would bring
us
to keep myself distracted i rolled up my
sleeves
and i went about finishing what he could
now no longer complete
the restoration of our old home
when that looming three-week deadline
came
and then went he was still alive
and at three months
he joined me
we gutted and repainted the interior
at six months the old windows where we
finished and at 18 months the rotted
porch was finally replaced
and there was my father
standing with me outside admiring a
day's work
hair on his head
fully in remission
when he turned to me and he said you
know michael this house saved my life
so
the following year i decided to go to
architecture school
but there i learned something different
about buildings
recognition seemed to come to those who
prioritized novel and sculptural forms
like
ribbons
or
pickles
uh
and i think this is supposed to be a
snail
something about this bothered me
why was it that the the best architects
the greatest architecture all beautiful
and visionary and innovative
is also so rare and seems to serve so
very few
and more to the point
with all of this creative talent what
more could we do
just as i was about to start my final
exams i decided to take a break from an
all-nighter
and go to a lecture by dr paul farmer
a leading health activist for the global
poor and i was surprised to hear a
doctor talking about architecture
buildings are making people sicker he
said and for the poorest in the world
this is causing epidemic level problems
in this hospital in south africa
patients that came in with say a broken
leg to wait in this unventilated hallway
walked out with a multi-drug resistant
strand of tuberculosis
simple designs for infection control had
not been thought about and people had
died because of it
where
are the architects paul said
if hospitals are making people sicker
where are the architects and designers
to help us
build and design hospitals that allow us
to heal
that following summer i was in the back
of a land rover with a few classmates
bumping over the mountainous hillside of
rwanda
for the next year i'd be living in
bhutaro in this old guest house which
was a jail
after the genocide
and i was there to design and build a
new type of hospital with dr farmer and
his team
if hallways are making patients sicker
what if we could design a hospital that
flips the hallways on the outside it
makes people walk in the exterior
if mechanical systems rarely work what
if we could design a hospital that could
breathe through natural ventilation and
meanwhile reduce its environmental
footprint
and what about the patient's experience
evidence shows that a simple view of
nature can radically improve health
outcomes
so why couldn't we design a hospital
where every patient had a window with a
view
simple
site-specific designs can make a
hospital that heals
designing it is one thing getting it
built we learned is quite another
we worked with bruce nizay
a brilliant engineer and he thought
about construction differently than i
had been taught in school
when we had to excavate this enormous
hilltop and a bulldozer was expensive
and hard to get to site bruce suggested
doing it by hand
using a method in rwanda called ubudeh
which means community works for the
community
hundreds of people came with shovels and
hoes
and we excavated that hill in half the
time and half the cost of that bulldozer
instead of importing furniture bruce
started a guild and he brought in master
carpenters to train others and how to
make furniture by hand and on this job
site 15 years after the rwandan genocide
bruce insisted that we bring on labor
from all backgrounds and that half of
them be women
bruce was using the process of building
to heal not just for those who were sick
but for the entire community
as a whole
we call this the locally fabricated way
of building or low-fab
and it has uh four pillars
higher locally source regionally
train where you can and most importantly
think about every design decision as an
opportunity to invest in the dignity of
the places and where you serve
think of it like the local food movement
but for architecture and we're convinced
that this way of building can be
replicated across the world and change
the way that we talk about and evaluate
architecture
using the low fab way of building even
aesthetic decisions can be designed to
impact people's
lives in bhutaro we chose to use a local
volcanic stone found in abundance within
the area but often considered a nuisance
by farmers and piled on the side of the
road
we worked with these masons to cut these
stones and form them
into the walls of the hospital and when
they began
on this corner and wrapped around the
entire hospital
they were so good at putting these
stones together they asked us if they
could take down the original wall and
rebuild it
and you see what is possible
it's beautiful
and the beauty to me
comes from the fact that i know that
hands cut these stones
and they form them into this thick wall
made only in this place with rocks from
this soil
when you go outside today and you look
at your built world
ask not only what is the environmental
footprint an important question but what
if we also asked what is the human
handprint
of those who made it
we started a new practice based around
these questions and we tested it
around the world
like in haiti where we asked if a new
hospital could help end the epidemic of
cholera
in this one hundred bed hospital we
designed a simple strategy to clean
contaminated medical waste before it
enters the water table and our partners
at lasalle trejescio are already saving
lives because of it
or malawi we asked if a birthing center
could radically reduce maternal and
infant mortality
malawi has one of the highest rates of
maternal infant death in the world using
a simple strategy to be replicated
nationally
we designed a birthing center that would
attract women and their attendants to
come to the hospital earlier and
therefore have safer births
or in the congo where we asked if an
educational center could also be used to
protect endangered wildlife poaching for
ivory and bushmeat is leading to global
epidemic disease transfer and war
in one of the hardest to reach places in
the world
we used the mud and the dirt and the
wood around us to construct a center
that would show us ways to protect and
conserve our rich biodiversity
even here in the us
we were asked to rethink the largest
university for the deaf and hard of
hearing in the world
the deaf community through sign language
shows us the power of visual
communication we designed a campus that
would awaken the ways in which we as
humans all communicate both verbally and
non-verbally
and even in poughkeepsie my hometown
we thought about old industrial
infrastructure
we wondered could we use arts and
culture and design to revitalize this
city and other rust-belt cities across
our nation and turn them into centers
for innovation and growth
in each of these projects we asked a
simple question
what more can architecture do
and by asking that question we're forced
to consider
how we could create jobs how we could
source regionally
and how we could invest in the dignity
of the communities in which we serve
i have
learned that architecture can be a
transformative engine for change
about a year ago
i read an article
about a tireless and intrepid civil
rights leader
named brian stevenson
and brian had a bold architectural
vision he and his team have been
documenting
the over 4 000 lynchings of african
americans that had happened in the
american south
and they had a plan
to mark every county where these
lynchings occurred and build a national
memorial to the victims of lynching in
montgomery alabama
countries like germany and south africa
and of course rwanda have found it
necessary to build memorials
to reflect on the atrocities of their
past
in order to heal their national psyche
we have yet to do this in the united
states
so
i sent a cold email to info at equal
justiceinitiative.org
dear brian it said
i think your building project is maybe
the most important project we could do
in america and change the way we think
about racial injustice
by uh
any chance do you know who will design
it
[Applause]
surprisingly shockingly
uh brian got right back to me invited me
down to meet with his team and talk to
them
needless to say i cancelled all my
meetings and i jumped on a plane to
montgomery alabama and when i got there
brian and his team picked me up and we
walked around the city and they took the
time to point out
the many markers that have been placed
all over the city to the history of the
confederacy and the very few
that mark the history of slavery and
then he walked me to a hill
and it overlooked the whole city
and he pointed out the river and the
train tracks where the largest domestic
slave trading port in america had once
prospered and then to the capitol
rotunda where george wallace had stood
on its steps and proclaimed segregation
forever
and then to the very hill below us and
he said here we will build a new
memorial that will change the identity
of this city and of this nation
our two teams have worked together over
the last year
to design this memorial
the memorial
will take us on a journey
through a classical almost familiar
building type like the parthenon or the
colonnade
at the vatican
but as we enter the ground drops below
us
and our perception shifts
we realize that these columns evoke the
lynchings
which happened in the public square
and as we continue we begin to
understand the vast number of those who
have yet to be put to rest and their
names will be engraved
on the markers that hang above us
and just outside
will be a field of identical columns
but these are temporary columns waiting
in purgatory to be placed in the very
counties of where these lynchings
occurred
over the next few years
this site will bear witness
as each of these markers is claimed and
visibly placed in those counties
our nation will begin to heal from over
a century of silence
and when we think about how it should be
built we were reminded of
uberdeje the building process we learned
about in rwanda
we wondered if we could fill those very
columns with the soil from the sites
where these killings occurred
brian and his team have begun collecting
that soil
and preserving it in individual jars
with family members community leaders
and descendants
the act of collecting soil itself
has led to a type of spiritual healing
it's an act of restorative justice
as one egi team member noted the
collection of soil from where will
mcbride was lynched
if will mcbride left one drop of sweat
one drop of blood
one hair follicle
i pray that i dug it up and that his
whole body would be at peace
we plan to break ground on this memorial
later this year and it will be a place
to finally speak of the unspeakable acts
that have scarred this nation
[Applause]
[Applause]
but my father told me that day that this
house
our house had saved his life
what i didn't know was that he's
referring to a much deeper relationship
between architecture and ourselves
buildings are not simply expressive
sculptures
they make visible our personal and our
collective aspirations as a society
great architecture can give us hope
great architecture can heal
thank you very much
[Applause]